hello everyone and welcome back to round
five of the 2021 multwater champions
chester today is a rest today so we will
not be having round six so we have time
to check up on a few games that we
haven't covered yesterday and a lot of
you guys have requested the second game
uh between magnus and hikar or rather
this is game three but the second game
we're going to show from their match so
as you know magnus won the first game
with the white pieces the second game
where hikaru had white ended in a draw
and now magnus again has the white
pieces uh and well uh this uh doesn't
need to be said but it is uh it is an
absolute beauty of a game
uh so let's check it out magnus with the
white pieces again opens with e4 if
you've seen the previous video where
they played that it was also a brilliant
defense but we're gonna discuss that uh
once we started the move so e5 knight to
f3 knight to c6 and bishop to b5 again
magnus goes for the royal opus and he
carry plays knight to f6 goes for the
berlin defense and again d3 not
interested in trading queens any anytime
soon we have bishop to c5 and bishop
captures on c6 we have d captures on c6
and magnus castles and now we discussed
that you have to
of course defend the e5 pawn there are
many ways to do this hikaru again goes
for bishop to d6 like in game one and
now magnus played knight b to d2 in the
previous game but here he goes for
bishop to g5 it's not a new move it has
been played before but only a handful of
games in the database uh it's uh
gear replayed it once and the furuga
played it um some three times so h6
challenging the bishop bishop to h4 and
now queen to e7 uh continuing
development uh we have knight beat to d2
this knight is going to c4 and now
bishop to g4 now pinning this knight and
there is even a game where furuja had
this position with the white pieces
against hikaru himself he was from the
2020 saint louis um
blitz tournament uh and uh hikaru won
that game with the black pieces furuji
just continued with knight to c4 but
magnus brings an improvement and that is
h3 it's a slight improvement uh
according to the engine but uh
an improvement nonetheless uh and of
course it is as of move tender we have a
completely new game so let's see uh how
hikaru continues he plays bishop to h5
still uh interested in
uh just uh keeping this pin on the board
uh and now while you could uh play some
like c3 maybe bring the knight into the
game maybe play bishop to g3 maybe
develop the rook uh many options but
magnus just strikes in the center with
the d4 and this is also a very tricky
move uh because if hikaru goes greedy
for example the
e captures on d4 it's not a free pawn
magnus just plays e5 and it's game over
hikaru can resign uh you're going to
lose a piece and even if you capture
here just rook to e1 now there's a
a double attack on the bishop on e5 and
even if you castle queen side let's say
okay the knight can't capture because
black would also capture white's queen
we can just play g4 push the bishop back
and now win a piece and of course
completely winning for magnus so hikaru
of course ignores this he plays uh queen
side castles and now rook to e1
we have queen to e6 finally unpinning
here
and now c4 another beautiful move by
magnus it's upon sacrifice but it's a
very deep pawn sacrifice that's not
really upon sacrifice you'll see what i
mean by this so hikaru grabs it he plays
bishop captures on f3
and now if you capture with the queen
then you no longer
defend your d4 pawn so magnus captures
with the knight and now hikaru just
grabs the c4 pawn now comes d captures
an e5 and now what do you play here both
of your pieces are attacked so he car
plays bishop captures on e5 exposing
this rook to the white queen and now
magnus just plays knight captures on e5
he grabs this bishop attacking hikaru's
queen and now he carries just sidesteps
with queen to b5 still attacking
carlson's queen but also putting
pressure on the knight on e5 this is uh
i believe the
uh position i've used on the thumbnail
uh so uh and that's for a very good
reason so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the only move that
allows magnus to keep the advantage
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
to what i was saying i was saying that
it was only a temporary pawn sacrifice
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is knight captures and
c6 you sacrifice your queen but not
really
because now if the queen is accepted for
example rook captures on d1 now we play
knight captures on a7 uh deliver a check
and we're going to win back the queen
king to b8 we're going to play knight
captures on b5 and we're up a bishop
regardless of what black plays let's say
characters captures we're up a bishop
and we're completely winning here so
after knight captures on c6 magnus uh he
covered played queen captures in c6 and
now queen to b3 and this is what i meant
when magnus played that c for move that
it's upon sacrifice but not really now
the material on the board is completely
equal magnus has a bishop against the
knight and now he has a semi-open c file
to be used for attacking purposes um
that's why that pawn sacrifice is so
nice you can put a rook on c1 maybe even
double rooks put a bishop and g3 control
this diagonal so it's going to be a lot
of pressure against hikaru's king so
rook the d7 preparing to bring the other
rook into the game and rook 8 to c1
we have queen to e6 now offering a queen
trade and magnus could uh continue uh
for with something like queen to a4 and
uh just try and uh keep this as an
attacking game but he says all right we
can trade queens i can mess up your pawn
structure you're gonna have three pawn
islands uh let's go straight into the
end game so queen captures on e6 f
captures on e6 and now bishop to g3
putting more pressure on this diagonal
now you can play some like rook c3
double rooks here play f3 to solidify in
the center and this is basically what
the magnus is playing so b6 he car wants
to play c5 and now magnus advances the
rook all the way to c6 prevents this
pawn from being pushed forward uh we
have rook to e8 as the e6 pawn is also
attacked and now uh if you continue with
rook e to c1 then hikaru can just block
this bishop with a move like e5 so
magnus plays bishop to e5 instead not
allowing hikaru this e5 move
and now king to b7 we have rook e to c1
now putting more pressure here and now
rook e to e7 this is how hikaru defends
and now it seems that everything is
perfectly defended how can you
try and make progress here well f3 and
we start by bringing our king into the
game
uh we have knight to the e8 by hikaru
and h4 now trying to grab more space
here so he car plays h5 doesn't allow
this and now king to h2 now you're
thinking about some like king g3 king of
four king to g5 maybe uh gobble up some
pawns here if he car allows it so here
hikaru plays g6 uh defends the pawn and
also uh removes uh this um a g7 pawn
from from being a constant uh
target for the bishop so king g3 and now
rook to d2 now hikaru activates his rook
and puts pressure uh here okay the b2
pawn is defended by the bishop but the
g2 pawn uh now the king can't really go
up the board uh you're gonna lose this
pawn so magnus has to defend uh he plays
rook 6 back to d2 and now rook captures
with rook captures and the rook to f7
not allowing the king any further and
now how do you make progress here well
the same way you always make progress in
any position with white you play b4 uh
so make sense uh because black would
very much like to start expanding here
on the queen side he has a three to two
advantage here on the queen side and of
course a huge rate of a pair of pawns
then you trade off another pair of pawns
and all of a sudden you're left with a
pass pawn so b4 prevents this because
now a5 would be a bit too ambitious you
can just trade for example and go rook
c5 you attack the pawn and it's a very
ugly position for black so hikaru plays
a6 wants to keep things flexible and now
a4 by magnus uh we have rook to f8 this
is a waiting move uh he just wants to
wait and see what magnus will do as
there is no way for black to make
progress here the bishop very nicely
controls all of the squares the knight
can jump to and the rook has to remain
here guarding the f4 square because if
you move it then the king reaches g5 and
it's game over
uh so here we have b5 by magnus a
captures a captures and now king to c8
so just waiting and see what happens
also the knight can't really move
because the c7 pawn would hang so rook
to a2 now by magnus trying to infiltrate
um uh the the queen side here king to d7
uh we have to a8 now we're putting
pressure on this knight if if the knight
moves and the the rooks get traded off
the board then it's gonna be very easy
for magnus to just pick off all of these
pawns but you can't really move the
knight the rook is still hanging so rook
to f7 now comes rook back to a1 by
magnus
and again how do you continue here we
have rook back to f8 he says all right i
i'm very happy with my position let's
call this a draw but now magnus has to
figure out a different way how to
activate and now he plays king to f2 now
he wants to bring the king to e3 and try
something else leave no stone unturned
as they say we have knight to d6 by
hikaru and now magnus says all right
you've defended well you're going after
my b5 pawn now it's trying time to go in
into the uh rook and pawn end game so
bishop captures and now uh you can't
capture with the c pawn even though you
get a nice spawn chain here in the
center that maybe you can even use to
create a pass pawn uh rook a7 check is
just too deadly uh now we're going to
play king
rook to b7 and pick up this pawn or if
the king tries to stop that rook 8 check
wins the rook so you can't really do
that you have to capture with the king
this is what hikaru does and now rook to
d1 with check here uh magnus is trying
to get hikaru to go after carlson's
b-pawn because if this happens then rook
the c1 check and now if you trade then
magnus captures on c7 and now he goes
after the king side pawn so whether this
is enough or not it's uh it's an attempt
definitely uh but after rook to d1 check
hikaru just uh uh you know wants to keep
everything cool so just a king to e7 and
now king to e3 by magnus now uh he might
be interested in infiltrating via the d4
square uh not right away you don't want
to play king d4 and then you blunder the
rook but the rook will move and then
somehow we're going to try and get the
king to e5 so here rook the a8 by hikaru
he tries to stop that e5 is a very
interesting attempt but it's a very
committal move and hikaru is very very
low on time so hikaru tries rook to a8
and now rook to c1 here magnus goes
after the c7 pawn king to d7 and now
finally king to f4 so the king was
already on g3 but the rook on f8 did not
allow the king to
reach the f4 square so magnus had to go
to f2 to e3 and then the key
then to f4 this is something you have to
do sometimes in just uh to try and make
progress so now rook to a2 going after
the g2 pawn and magnus advances it to g4
we have a3 now preventing the king from
advancing any further otherwise we're
going to lose the f3 pawn so
rook to f1 this is how magnus defends
and now he's going after that g pawn so
king e7 hikaru has to defend that king
to g5 now king to f7
and now king to h6 a very important move
uh rook to c3 and not magnus even grabs
more space he plays g5 now takes away
another crucial square for from the
black king and now if something like
rook to d1 rook to d7 check happens
that's all over uh so rook the d3 of
course he will try to prevent this but
now rook the c1 going after the pawn and
now rook to d7 so hikaru defending
extremely well here being very low on
time
but magnus always has a way to improve
rook to c6 and now
hikaru is simply running out of moves
the rook has to keep an eye on the pawn
here the king has to keep an eye on this
pawn and on this pawn you really don't
have a good move your only reasonable
move is rook to e7 but now magnus just
continues increasing the pressure f4 uh
we have rook to d7 hikaru is forced to
repeat moves and now f5 uh this f5
ensures that we get a past g pawn
regardless of what black plays so g
captures on f5 we have e captures on f5
uh e captures on f5 and now rook to f6
with check now magnus will eliminate
this spawn uh from f5 this rook will
defend the b5 pawn and then he will
finally grab the h5 pawn and this is how
magnus wins a pawn so this was all to
win a pawn so kink the g8 and now rook
captures an f5 this is now uh nicely
defended so rook to d6 check and king
captures an h5 and now you have two
connected pass points on the king side
and of course this is more than enough
to to win the game so c6 now hikaru has
to play something he creates a pass pawn
on the queen side b captures rook
captures and now g6 uh here
you always have to check a move like
rook to c5 if it's working uh because uh
if it is then it's winning unfortunately
it's not magnus could just trade and
after captures we're going to play king
g5 c4 king to f4 and you can see that
the king is well within the square of
the pawn so of course the pawn can be
stopped so after g6 we have rooked the
c8 by hikaru now comes king to g5 and
now of course our h pawn is marching
forward we have rooked the b8 hikaru
puts the rook behind the pass pawn but
now h5 here hikaru played b5 but he was
also in this position on move 60 uh that
hikaru nakamura resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here he
was uh down to maybe some 17 seconds and
the clock magnus had like five and a
half minutes so it wasn't really
um
it was really
a possibility of magnus making a mistake
or something uh so here you resign
because it's uh it's actually a forced
check made in a few moves uh just uh to
show you because you guys enjoyed this
so much uh h6 we're going to play b4 now
h7 check king to g7 rook dev seven check
king to h8 and now king to h6 we're
gonna check mate to the black king with
the pawn uh and there's nothing black
can do about this if you pin the pawn we
just deliver rook to f8 to checkmate so
regardless of what black plays
you know uh black is getting checkmated
uh so after b5 hikaru resigned which
means that as magnus won game one drew
game two and one game three that magnus
wins the match and um that's it there
there will be no game four so both game
one and game two were very very
instructive on how to counter the berlin
defense uh you know it would be great if
kasparov knew this when he had his world
championship match against kramnik uh
but you can see that they they avoided
the drawish lines and here magnus was
able to find some play uh in both of the
games but hikaru defended extremely well
in both of the games it's just a matter
of uh you know magnus always making the
the absolute best or maybe the second
absolute best move and hikaru making uh
you know the second absolute best move
and maybe the third absolute best move
and then over the course of 10 moves uh
it's just enough uh advantage to you
know go for for a win so that that's how
i see uh these two games against the
berlin defense but it's it's a great
victory uh you know uh just uh giving us
hope that there is uh the possibility of
beating the berlin defense
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
happy birthday to jorge castle uh and
also a happy birthday to alistar
fitzgerald uh and i would like to thank
uh andre frantischek balcovich
enterprises and uh ben mcgregorian for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day